ううっうぅうううおおおおおお
2012年9月15日ホテルオークラ神戸にて5万円になりますがよろしいでしょうか
今頃僕は奄美大島に入るはずだった透明な海を望むホテルで陳腐な文章を書いたり
誇大妄想にふけったりしているはずだっただけど台風12号が奄美大島を直撃した
それでどうしても休みの間にどっかに
行きたかった暴行準備しておいた荷物と20万円も入った封筒をそのまま手にしてあて
もなく家を出た
昨日の朝僕が名古屋に行った時に封筒の中にまだ9万円も入っていたが今こうして神戸
のホテルオークラについてみると
封筒の中に6万円しか入っていない客様この部屋後前になりますがよろしいでしょうか
缶コーヒー500本分これはかなり痛い
食事は別ですかはい別になりますざけんなよ5万円だろうと思ったら荷物もう一回
持ち上げて違うホテルし探すのがなんだか無性にめんどくさくなり
抵抗しなかったわかりましたじゃあ花がし
ますかしこまりましたではご案内いたしますきつね色の制服を着ているお姉さんが
そっと笑われこちらになりますと白い手袋に包まれた手を上に向けて歩き出すこの所と
一緒に天井の高いロビーを横切りその反対側にあるエレベーターに乗り込む近くの
ビジネスホテルでも全然良かった形と自分を責めながら何気なく月子の山をに戻した
ことに
不思議な感動を覚えるすごい人だと思われてるに違いない
一人で高級ホテルのは室空いてに留まるような謎に包まれた人
壁に書いてある赤い数字が大きくなるにつれて
僕の妄想夢を拡大していたこちらです桃姐さんが開きだした道の間に手を差し出す今度
は先に出て行くでも待っていたその間に自分が謎に包ま
れたすごい人でやることを思い出しさっと彼女の前を突っ切る
お姉さんをすぐに追い越してきて日本にいらして何年目ですかと振り返って聞く3年目
になります問いかけたかその間に再び思い出す
僕はナスの男だ何年目でしょう
この所一瞬こけそうなったら何事もなかったかのように決まって笑顔を浮かべる
日本語お上手ですねけっある大学で勉強しましたので
だから上手なんですねそう言いながら彼女短いって言えるか言えないかぐらいの
スカートから伸びてる足を静かに前へと進め続ける僕はしばらく州のしなやかな動きに
取るのに気付いたら食
地別1泊5万円もそりゃ部屋のドアの前で立ち止まっている本物の謎の男のでここで
ワクワクしないだろうと思いテンション高から注意のとするお姉さんがカードをドアに
挿入しカチッと音がする
ドアが開くと同時にため息が出る結婚式ができるんじゃないかと思えるぐらい広くて
綺麗な和室新しい畳の香りいくら探しても見
疲れないスピーカーから流れるモーツァルトのピアノバルコニーの前の啓発本乗ってい
そうな白石のには何か質問はございますか
靴棚の上に置いてある部屋の地図らしきものに愕然としている僕は
はいと思わず聞き返すそして何かの質問しなければならないように気がしてこのホテル
にはレストランがありますか
米と訳の分からない質問してしまう謎の男のイメージが薄れていくのがわかり少し
悲しくなるはい5つございますその中の3つはこの部屋にあるに違いないと思いながら
何時間やってますか
と僕はより合理的
質問する5時半からですお姉さん可愛い花萌実
他にご質問がございましたらフロントにをではと言って丁寧に会釈するそしてそっと
後ろを向いてドアを開ける彼女が兵を出る前に一度こちらを見て微笑むことを願ってい
たが振り返らずに出ていた
この所とともに僕の謎が去っていくような気がしへとてもうつろな気持ちになった
封筒には1万円しか残っていないとても神秘さが買える金額ではしばらく玄関で
ぼんやりしてから
僕は鋳造を手に取り浴室に向かったスイートの風呂で少し教養吸い取れば本物の謎男に
近づけると思ったんだ
[音楽]
car
me